lo que quiero realizar en este vídeo es
hablar de continuidad y continuidad en
una función es algo que es súper fácil
de identificar al verlo pero también
vamos a hablar más adelante de cómo
podríamos definirlo más rigurosamente y
es que cuando digo que es realmente
fácil de reconocer para que te queda más
claro también a ti dibujemos algunas
gráficas de funciones por aquí y bien
este sea nuestro eje de la siesta ahora
dibujemos nuestro eje de las equis y
vamos a dibujar una función una función
que se vendrá comportando algo así parte
desde aquí y continúa continua más
adelante de esta forma a luciendo así y
este intervalo abarca desde aquí del 0
hasta este punto de acá y ahora la
pregunta sería es esta función continua
y tú me dirías no pues no lo es pues
mira aquí sobre lo que vemos de la
función brinca de repente de este punto
a este de acá entonces no es continua
entonces esto no es continuo no es
continuo y podrás incluso decir que
tenemos una discontinuidad en este valor
que vemos aquí podríamos llamarlo como
una discontinuidad
de salto entonces tú puedes muy bien
decir esto no es continuo y es un tanto
obvio dado que estas partes no hacen
conexión de ninguna forma
entonces similarmente si ahora
quisiéramos realizar otra función otra
función está nuestro eje de leyes este
va a ser nuestro eje de las x
y nuestra función se va a comportar de
la siguiente forma sale a partir de aquí
y viene hacia arriba aquí tenemos un
espacio indefinido y el punto que
tenemos por acá arriba y ahora viene la
misma pregunta es esta función continua
sobre el intervalo que hemos dibujado y
también me dirías no no lo es porque la
función en este punto sube y de esta
forma es un tipo de discontinuidad así
que esta es la discontinuidad a la cual
nosotros podríamos llamarle desmontable
o bien aquí mejor conocida como una
discontinuidad evitable y podríamos
decir que este argumento de evitable es
porque redefiniendo la función no
pareciera discontinua al tener este
punto este punto al tenerlo relleno aquí
abajo tendríamos ya una función
completamente continua así que lo que
podría hacer es remover dicha
discontinuidad pero bueno finalmente
vamos a mencionar y vamos a dibujar otra
función así que déjame dibujar el eje x
y este es el eje de la yes y la función
va a venir definida de cierta forma aquí
y entonces aquí la pregunta es la misma
no está
es continuar y entonces tú me podrías
argumentar que sí pues es continua en
todos y cada uno de sus puntos que se
encuentran dentro de la parte de la
gráfica de la función y si hubiera algo
fuera de ella pues no sería continua así
que tú estarías en lo correcto y en
general este es el gran sentido de la
continuidad y yo creo que si tuvieras
otra gráfica podrías identificarlo
rápidamente pero vamos a pensar en algo
más estricto o riguroso para definirla y
pues recordando cuando nosotros entramos
de una forma rigurosa con las
definiciones de límites de épsilon si
deltas esta definición nos podría ayudar
para comprender mejor el tema de
continuidad y para crear esto la
definición más rigurosa de continuidad
vamos a pensar en alguna función que
tenga algunos intervalos entonces vamos
a trazar nuestra gráfica y aquí vamos a
tener lo vamos a dibujar por acá y vamos
a tener el eje de las 10 nuestro eje de
láseres y por acá nuestro eje de las
equis y si observas un poco estas
gráficas que tenemos por acá estamos
dentro de algunos intervalos para marcar
de qué punto a qué punto iban entonces
aquí vamos a marcar nuestro intervalo de
la función
este sería el extremo final nuestros
ejes y ahora vamos a trazar nuestra
dicha función que va a ir de cada
extremo del intervalo entonces se
comporta algo así y podríamos decir que
dicha función es continua ahora vamos a
agregar un punto interior en dicha
función que no cumple exactamente con el
tamaño de los bordes y dicho punto
interior aún así está dándole un efecto
continuo a nuestra función entonces
nosotros podríamos llamar que dicha
función es continua en el punto en el
intervalo y ahora bien lo que esto nos
está diciendo es que el límite el límite
cuando x se aproxima a c vamos a
llamarle sea dicho punto que nosotros
trazamos en nuestra función
entonces el límite el límite de fx donde
f x es la función que nosotros trazamos
por aquí y dicho el límite cuando x se
aproxima a se nos va a ser igual a un f
de c lo que estamos diciendo es que
dicho punto o bien fdc en la gráfica que
es el límite se estará aproximando a
ésta
lo mismo que el valor en la función lo
que esto ya hace un gran sentido y ahora
ya pensando o imaginando dicho contexto
podría pasar algo parecido hablando en
cuanto a continuidad y bueno en este
caso digamos que nuestro se va a ser
este punto de por acá y esto va a hacer
efe de c y bueno en este caso el límite
de fx cuando x se aproxima a c sea igual
a c estaríamos pidiendo que dicho límite
se acercará por la parte derecha por la
posición positiva de este lado de la
gráfica para que nos diera cierto límite
que nos diera que esto es igual a fcc
pero bueno esto no es igual cuando
decimos que el límite de fx cuando x
aproxima hace por la izquierda no nos va
a dar que esto sea igual a efe bc y por
dicha razón esta función no es continua
puesto que todo el límite debería de ser
igual a fcc hablando en cuanto a las dos
direcciones y pues este no es
entonces esto no nos muestra lo que
nosotros queríamos lograr con nuestra
definición formal lo cual es bueno
porque nosotros visualmente
identificamos que dicha función no era
continua y pasando de este lado y
borrando el punto que habíamos marcado y
entonces aquí aquí veamos nuestro límite
primero vamos a definir que por aquí
tenemos nuestro punto ce y el límite de
fx cuando x se aproxima hace digamos que
es igual a l y es que aquí hay que mirar
ciertos aspectos aquí tenemos donde no
está definido entonces ese va a ser el y
nuestro punto clave se encuentra arriba
entonces él y nunca va a ser igual a efe
de ese puesto que nosotros podemos
visualizar fcc hasta acá y entonces una
vez más vemos que éste no cumple con
nuestra prueba de continuidad pues el
límite de fx no es igual a fs por lo que
una vez más no pasa a nuestra prueba y
bueno en nuestro último caso aquí si
nuestra prueba va a pasar completamente
puesto que todos los puntos están bien
definidos para nuestra función en su
intervalo lo cual también es bueno
porque desde el principio nosotros
habíamos acertado
dicha función era continua pero bueno
ahora vamos a dar una definición de lo
que hemos estado nosotros hablando de
acuerdo a nuestros ejemplos así que esta
es una función continua para un punto
interior y vamos a pensar en continuidad
la continuidad en el punto interior lo
vamos a escribir por acá abajo pues
estamos hablando de continuidad y había
puesto aquí que con respecto al borde
pero para no confundirlo con el límite
vamos a poner lo que es al final del
punto al final del punto ce entonces
primero vamos a considerar el lado
izquierdo del punto final así que si
nosotros tuviéramos el punto final y nos
fijáramos de su lado izquierdo como
vamos a empezar a hablar de esto me
gustaría graficar lo para que se viera
un poco más claro mi eje x michele y
ahora tendremos por acá el punto inicial
de nuestro intervalo y este nuestro
punto final
entonces dibujando nuestra función sobre
este intervalo que luce así y luce la
función algo así nosotros estamos
hablando de nuestro punto izquierdo
pensando en
lo siguiente que nuestro punto se inicia
aquí y este es el punto final izquierdo
y hablando de esto vamos en cuanto a
continuidad la continuidad en celo que
nos diría lo que significaría sería que
el límite de fx cuando x se aproxima a c
puede inclusive acercarse del lado
derecho más no del lado izquierdo
entonces nosotros podemos acercarnos por
la derecha y aproximarnos a efe de c y
bueno esta es una especie de
aproximación en cuanto a una dirección
nosotros podemos decir que estábamos
haciendo algo parecido a lo que hicimos
por acá pero en este caso estamos
aproximándonos simplemente en una sola
dirección a nuestro punto que tenemos
por aquí que sería en esta dirección y
en conclusión podemos nosotros
determinar que ese punto es continuo
ahora también podríamos pensar en donde
el punto no fuera continuo en dicha
situación y entonces vamos a hacer la
gráfica para que luzca de una mejor
forma este es nuestro
en nuestro eje x y nuestra gráfica va a
estar dentro de este intervalo y se
comporta de la siguiente forma aquí
tenemos el punto aquí está indefinido y
la gráfica viene algo así entonces
podríamos decir que tenemos una especie
de discontinuidad evitable o visualmente
podemos decir que es eso y entonces aquí
lo que pasaría es que la prueba no se
completaría pues el límite si lo
aproximamos hace del lado derecho lo que
tenemos es l pues f que se encuentra en
la parte superior donde si estaba
definido el punto entonces aunque nos
acercamos por el lado derecho esta
función no será continua y bueno ahora
podemos imaginar qué podría pasar si
nosotros re dibujáramos el punto y
dijéramos que es continua por la derecha
en el punto c así que qué les parece si
también lo dibujamos sé que me tardó un
poquito haciendo esto de las gráficas
pero es para que quede mucho más claro a
la vista entonces aquí tenemos nuestro
eje x este es nuestro eje y aquí
tendremos nuestro intervalo para dicha
función y en este caso nuestro punto ce
se va a encontrar en este extremo y
podemos decir bueno aquí nuestra función
aquí en este caso cuando x es igual a c
y en este caso nosotros nos podemos
acercar a nuestro punto importante por
la izquierda entonces el límite de fx
cuando x se aproxima a c aquí lo tenemos
que aproximar por la izquierda y
entonces si decimos esto entonces
estamos contemplando que es continua en
ese sentido en esta dirección hacia el
punto c y viceversa que es lo que
hicimos en la situación anterior pero
fue de otro extremo y éste fue en
nuestro extremo derecho finalmente la
continuidad no es realmente complicada
de entender pues la idea es donde quiera
que tú veas que la función está
brincando teniendo una especie de
espacio o brecha es realmente intuitivo
ver que ahí no hay una función con
continuidad puesto que no está conectada
así que en este vídeo utilizamos lo que
ya sabíamos de límites para tener una
mejor definición
en cuanto a continuidad